Pour Joëlle Rivière,
c'est toujours la même émotion
lorsqu'il s'installe au volant.
Vous êtes un privilégié
-Ah oui.
Enorme privilégié.
Le pouvoir.
Entendre ce doux bruit
d'un V12 Ferrari derrière le dos.
Directement inspiré
de la Formule un,
sa voiture est l'une
des plus puissantes au monde.
Vitesse de pointe :
350 kilomètres par heure.
Vous avez l'impression
de monter dans un engin futuriste,
de monter
dans un engin hors du commun.
C'est très important.
Et puis,
dans cette voiture,
vous avez cette odeur,
cette odeur de cuir,
cette odeur de carbone.
Les accélérations
sont assez démoniaques quand même,
on passe le zéro à 100
en 3,6 secondes.
Très rapide
et très chère.
Cet ancien PDG d'une société informatique
a dû débourser 675 000 € pour sa voiture.
Pour lui,
c'est le rêve de toute une vie.
Au départ,
quand j'ai vu dans les livres,
tout petit,
ce genre de voiture rouge,
j'ai dit :
c'est ça qu'il faut avoir plus tard.
Le nom de cette voiture : la Enzo,
en hommage
au fondateur de la marque,
Enzo Ferrari,
décédé en 1988.
Cet ancien
pilote italien a construit
un mythe autour
de ses voitures en moins de 60 ans.
Géant de la course automobile
avec ses drames
et son record de victoires,
mais aussi créateur
de cabriolets de luxe
pour les stars de Hollywood
et les puissants de ce monde.
Même le pape Jean-Paul II en était fan.
Comment
Enzo Ferrari a-t-il bâti sa légende ?
Comment les voitures
les plus chères du monde
sont construites ?
Qui sont les milliardaires
et les collectionneurs
prêts à tout
pour ces belles Italiennes ?
Enquête au cœur
de l'entreprise Ferrari.
La saga Ferrari,
c'est surtout
de cet homme au destin exceptionnel,
Enzo Ferrari.
Il naît en 1898 à Modène,
dans une Italie
qui découvre les sports mécaniques.
Le petit Enzo,
fils de mécanicien,
succombe à la passion
du sport automobile.
Et à 20 ans,
il décide de devenir pilote
pour gagner sa vie.
Le voici dans
de sa première voiture,
une Formule un de l'époque.
Surdoué du pilotage
et mécanicien hors pair,
il transforme les tacots
qu'on lui confie en vrais bolides
et remporte
plusieurs courses prestigieuses.
Comme ce jour de 1924
où une comtesse italienne
l'attend après la ligne d'arrivée.
Séduite par le vainqueur,
elle lui offre cet écusson
figurant un cheval cabré.
Une drôle d'histoire
qui va devenir une légende.
Enzo n'est plus là
pour la raconter,
mais un autre homme
la connaît par cœur.
C'est son fils,
Piero Ferrari.
C'est encore un plaisir pour vous
de conduire une Ferrari ?
Oui,
c'est toujours un plaisir.
J'en conduis depuis que j'ai 18 ans
et je ne m'en lasse pas.
Pierrot est vice président de Ferrari.
Le cheval cabré est l'emblème
de l'entreprise fondée par son père.
L'histoire du cheval est bien vieille.
Quand mon père était pilote,
c'est la mère d'un as
de l'aviation italienne
appelé Francesco Barraca,
qui le lui a offert,
en guise de porte bonheur,
Francesco Barraca
avait choisi le cheval cabré
comme symbole de l'intrépidité.
Il est mort au combat
en héros national.
Mon père l'a adopté
comme emblème
quand il a fondé son équipe.
Il a ajouté le fond jaune,
couleur de Modène,
sa ville natale.
Le logo de la marque est né.
Enzo Ferrari
le plaque alors sur toutes les voitures
destinées aux courses.
dans les années 30,
fini le pilotage,
le génie de la mécanique
est appelé à de plus hautes fonctions.
Il dirige tout le département compétition
d'un prestigieux constructeur italien,
Alfa Romeo.
Malgré les victoires,
c'est la brouille.
Les dirigeants d'Alfa Romeo détestent
son caractère arrogant,
orgueilleux et autoritaire.
Enzo Ferrari n'aime pas perdre
et ne supporte pas les ordres,
à l'image de son personnage
historique préféré.
Vous admirez beaucoup Napoléon
pourquoi ?
J'ai lu beaucoup
de choses sur Napoléon.
C'était un très bon général,
un mathématicien
hors pair aussi.
Il suffit de voir
le siège de Toulon.
C'était aussi un bon législateur,
et un grand séducteur.
Finis Alfa Romeo,
le Napoléon de la course auto
se retrouve sans de voiture,
fin des années 30.
Tout aurait pu s'arrêter là.
Ce sont les coups de canons
qui vont faire basculer son destin.
La Seconde Guerre mondiale éclate.
Mussolini est allié à Hitler.
Dans l'Italie fasciste, Enzo Ferrari
doit participer à l'effort de guerre.
Il crée son propre
atelier de mécanique
et construit
de petits moteurs d'avions.
Mais en secret,
l'ancien pilote esquisse
la voiture de course
qu'il rêve de construire
une fois la paix revenue.
C'est chose faite en 1947.
Enzo Ferrari installe une usine
à son nom à Maranello,
au sud de Modène.
Il présente la 125 S,
sa première voiture.
Un petit bijou
qui séduit par son élégance
et qui triomphe sur circuit.
La voiture remporte
d'étonnantes victoires
à plus de 180 kilomètres par heure,
un record à l'époque.
La fabrication des premières Ferrari
va avec la création
du grand championnat de Formule un,
au début des années 50.
C'est sur les circuits
de Grand Prix
que la marque va se bâtir
une notoriété internationale.
Les pilotes sont les nouveaux aventuriers
de ce monde d'après guerre,
et les pilotes Ferrari
enchaînent les victoires,
comme ici au Grand Prix d'Allemagne.
Mais c'est surtout
le légendaire Fangio
qui va intéresser
les médias sur Ferrari.
Comme ici en 1956,
lorsque Fangio devient champion du monde.
Et un autre Grand Prix
le pour le pilote
qui est devenu une légende.
Mais la course,
ça coûte très cher.
Enzo Ferrari a une idée toute simple.
Il décline ces engins de course
en version berline et cabriolet de luxe
pour les vendre à de riches passionnés
voulant la même voiture que Fangio.
L'argent récolté
sert à financer la compétition.
Cette idée toute simple
est un vrai coup de génie,
selon Francis Monsnerg,
journaliste et auteur,
sur l'histoire de la marque.
Le nerf de Ferrari,
c'était vraiment là,
sa raison d'être
c'était uniquement la course.
Ferrari dira :
" si je vends des voitures,
que les gens vont pouvoir
utiliser au quotidien,
je vais avoir là,
une source de revenus formidable.
Et ça marche.
Le roi Léopold de Belgique,
la princesse Marie-Gabrielle de Savoie
ou encore le réalisateur
Roberto Rossellini,
tout le monde veut une Ferrari.
On court à Maranello
et c'est Enzo Ferrari
qui remet les clés en personne.
Même l'acteur et réalisateur français
de la Nouvelle Vague Roger Vadim,
viendra chercher
ce modèle de 1961
pour l'offrir
à Brigitte Bardot.
Ferrari devient très présent
dans les magazines,
dans les journaux.
C'est un marketing vivant.
Avec le futur people,
les gens achètent
des voitures sur mesure.
Tout le monde,
toutes personnalités
ou toutes les célébrités d'Hollywood
ont envie d'avoir une Ferrari.
Et ce commerce qui au départ
n'était qu'un moyen
de faire rentrer de l'argent
pour financer l'activité courses,
devient une activité
fondamentale de chez Ferrari.
Enzo Ferrari
construit des modèles uniques.
C'est ce qui plaît
aux stars et aux puissants.
Alors,
il va exploiter le filon.
Dans l'atelier de Maranello,
les carrosseries sont assemblées une à une
et chaque moteur,
coulé à la main.
Résultat : peu de voitures
produites chaque année
et une liste d'attente
de deux ans environ.
Fin stratège,
le Napoléon de Maranello a compris
qu'en produisant peu,
il stimulait chez une élite
et faisait monter les prix.
Cette stratégie
industrielle basée sur la rareté,
c'est Enzo Ferrari
qu'il a décidé dès le début,
et elle n'a jamais changé.
Nous sommes à Maranello.
Voici l'usine Ferrari aujourd'hui.
Plus vraiment
l'atelier des années 60.
Un complexe industriel
de 250 hectares,
l'équivalent
de 50 terrains de football.
Une ville dans la ville,
avec ses voitures en rodage,
ses bâtiments ultramodernes,
son avenue centrale
et ses rues perpendiculaires.
Chacune porte le nom
d'un champion du monde maison.
Un peu plus loin,
Ferrari possède même
cette piste d'essais privée
pour roder ses voitures
et tester ses prototypes.
Tout ici
est d'une propreté impeccable.
On pourrait manger par terre,
s'il n'y avait pas
cet énorme restaurant d'entreprise.
Aujourd'hui,
Ferrari emploie plus de 3000 salariés.
Ils produisent les voitures
les plus chères au monde
avec les techniques
les plus révolutionnaires.
Direction cette unité
de montage au cœur de l'usine.
Ici, on fabrique
le dernier modèle,
le coupé cabriolet California.
Voici l'homme
qui a conçu la chaîne de montage,
Cristiano Amoretti.
Tu as bien modifier phares ?
Oui, c'est la quatrième,
-OK, la quatrième.
Sous ses ordres, quelques mécanos,
mais surtout une armée de robots.
Cette unité d'assemblage
ultramoderne a été dessinée
par l'architecte français
Jean Nouvel.
Elle concentre toutes
les dernières technologies.
On utilise ces énormes mâchoires.
C'est très beau à voir.
Mais surtout,
les mâchoires pivotent,
ce qui permet
de tourner la voiture.
Les ouvriers travaillent
donc avec les bras à l'horizontale.
Fini le cambouis, ce n'est
plus vraiment un garage à l'ancienne.
Quand elles ne tombent pas du ciel,
elles sont transportées par robots.
D'un côté, la carrosserie,
de l'autre le moteur monté sur ces roues.
Les deux parties s'assemblent
comme par magie,
sans aucune
intervention humaine.
Cette ligne de montage
et ce complexe sont uniques au monde.
C'est une vraie révolution
dans notre processus de fabriquation.
Des robots
et un compte à rebours.
Chaque étape de la construction
ne doit pas dépasser la demi-heure.
L'horloge calcule
l'avancement de la ligne
et toutes les 30 minutes,
c'est elle qui donne le tempo.
Toutes les 30 minutes,
c'est toute la chaîne de fabrication
montée sur tapis roulant
qui avance en même temps.
Direction l'étape suivante.
Les mécaniciens ne sont là que
pour serrer les boulons.
En revanche,
tout ce qui concerne le montage du moteur,
l'installation de certains accessoires,
tout ce qui donne
de la valeur à la voiture,
ça, on continue
à le faire à la main.
Des petites mains
pour une voiture version haute couture.
Juste à côté de la chaîne de montage,
un bataillon de machines à coudre
et d'immenses
pièces de cuir taillées au laser.
À chaque découpes,
de quoi habiller
un tableau de bord version grand luxe.
Chaque pièce est ajustée
au millimètre près.
La matière, le coloris,
tout a été choisi et payé d'avance.
Toutes ces voitures sont au goût
de chaque clients.
Si on regarde celle-ci
par exemple,
on va voir
sa destination.
Celle-ci est
pour un client Français.
Il a choisi le rouge course
pour la peinture,
du cuir pour les finitions intérieures
et des écussons sur les côtés.
Cette voiture est unique
de par ces options.
Résultat une voiture
cousue main à 170 000 €, prix d'entrée.
Et c'est loin d'être fini.
Pour la valoriser,
de l'autre côté
il y a Federico Pastorelli.
À chaque
commande de Ferrari,
Le client passe chez lui
pour choisir les options.
Bienvenue !
Entrée dans mon atelier.
ici, les clients peuvent
personnaliser leur voiture à 100 %
Choisir la forme de la calandre,
la taille des jantes,
la finition des sièges
et même la couleur des étriers de freins.
Avec Federico, tout est possible,
à condition d'y mettre le prix.
C'est à peu près 800 €.
Juste pour changer les couleurs ?
- Oui.
Et pour dix fois plus,
Federico propose une option fibre
de carbone, version formule un.
Le volant de serie,
il est en aluminium,
mais on peut
choisir la fibre de carbone.
Voilà un exemple
avec ces diodes sur le volant.
Sur la porte aussi,
on peut rajouter
de la fibre de carbone.
L'option la plus chère,
c'est la couleur de la carrosserie.
Le client peut choisir
parmi seize couleurs de base,
mais on propose
aussi dix couleurs en option,
inspirées de certains
modèles des années 50 et 60.
Et c'est cher ?
- Non, pas tant que ça.
7 000 €.
En moyenne, ça fait au total,
onze ou 12 000 € d'options par voitures.
12000 € !
Les options chez Ferrari,
c'est le prix d'une petite voiture neuve
chez un constructeur français.
Une autre option très importante,
c'est l'écusson.
Neuf clients sur dix le veulent.
Et combien ça coûte ?
- Aux alentours de 1 000 €.
Ici,
rien de gratuit.
Au final, c'est une voiture
à 200 000 € en moyenne
qui sera vendue.
Et même à ce prix,
c'est la moins chère des Ferrari.
Comme au temps d'Enzo,
la production est volontairement limitée.
Des voitures comme celle-ci,
on n'en fabrique que seize par jour.
Les clients doivent payer d'avance
et patienter deux ans
en moyenne
sur une liste d'attente.
Pour le vice président,
Piero Ferrari,
pas question
d'arrêter cette limitation volontaire
de la production,
instaurée par son père.
Mon père disait toujours :
une Ferrari doit être désirée.
Elles sont
construites une par une,
sur mesure
pour chaque client.
Et ça,
ça se mérite.
Vous n'avez pas de stocks
et c'est normal ?
Oui,
c'est normal.
Et en cette période
de crise économique,
c'est très important
pour nous de ne pas avoir de stocks.
Pas de stocks,
une voiture prépayée,
un carnet de commandes plein
deux ans à l'avance.
C'est le secret
de la bonne santé de Ferrari,
deux milliards d'euros
de chiffre d'affaires en 2008,
record historique.
La marque se paie le luxe de
n'avoir jamais fait la moindre publicité.
Selon Jacques Séguéla,
le célèbre publicitaire français,
c'est un cas très rare
et on le doit au génie d'Enzo Ferrari.
Ça, c'est remarquable,
alors c'est l'Enzo.
Il est génial, car il a tout compris
de la publicité non payante.
Car il aura, grâce à sa formule un
et grâce à la beauté de ses voitures,
toute la presse du monde
pour faire gratuitement sa publicité,
alors que
les autres vont payer très cher
pour se faire connaître.
Et il va chaque fois
signer de cette couleur rouge
qui est un rouge unique,
différent
du rouge Saint Laurent
ou du rouge de Coca-Cola.
Qui est qui est le rouge Ferrari,
qui porte bien son nom
et que personne
ne va jamais lui voler.
Ce rouge,
Enzo Ferrari l'a choisi tout simplement
car c'était exigé
aux voitures italiennes
dans les compétitions
internationales d'avant guerre.
Mais, fin des années 60,
les rouges gagnent moins.
Les ventes stagnent et surtout,
les coûts de production, trop chers,
alors que la crise économique
des années 70 s'annonce.
Enzo Ferrari décide alors de s'allier
à Giovanni Agnelli, le patron de Fiat.
Le géant automobile
italien a fait fortune
sur un créneau
totalement différent,
celui de la voiture populaire,
petite et pas chère,
la fameuse Fiat 500.
Le mariage des extrêmes
a lieu le 21 juin 1969.
À 71 ans, El commendatores,
comme on le surnomme,
se résout à céder 50 % de l'entreprise
qu'il a créée de ses propres mains.
Ce jour là, son fils Piero,
à gauche sur la photo l'accompagne.
C'était un jour
triste pour votre père ?
Oui,
céder la moitié de sa créature,
une société qu'il avait mis
tant d'énergie à construire,
c'est forcément triste.
Mais, la production cessait
d'être un problème quotidien.
C'est désormais Fiat
qui nommait les managers
et gérait tout l'aspect industriel.
Vous pensez
que ça a sauvé Ferrari ?
Bien sûr.
Ça a permis à l'entreprise
de se développer, de se moderniser.
Mon père s'est concentré
sur sa passion,
la course automobile.
Et ça,
jusqu'à sa mort.
Fini l'esprit Ferrari ?
Pas du tout.
l'Alliance avec Fiat
permet de traverser la crise.
Les chaînes de montage
de Maranello se modernisent
et certains modèles vont même
connaître une renommée inattendue,
comme cette 308 rendue
célèbre par un détective moustachu.
Dans la série Magnum,
elle devient une vedette planétaire.
Grâce à Tom Selleck,
il s'est vendu plus de 308
que tous les autres
modèles de la marque depuis 1947.
Et pourtant,
ce n'est pas totalement une Ferrari.
Selon le journaliste Francis Monsnergue,
c'est aussi un peu une Fiat.
Ça se voit
sur certains accessoires.
Vous avez ici, par exemple,
de petites manettes.
Voilà, des choses comme-ça
ou des touches que vous pouvez retrouver
à plat sur les consoles sont de petits
accessoires qui étaient achetés chez Fiat
et qui permettaient
de faire des économies.
Des économies compensées
par de belles trouvailles techniques,
comme ces phares escamotables
qui vont faire de la 308
un must
chez les gens pressés.
Sur l'autoroute,
c'était super
car les gens vous voyaient
venir dans le retroviseur,
vos phares étaient dissuasifs.
Et vous deveniez
le roi du monde.
Se sentir puissant
au volant d'une Ferrari,
un sentiment qui pousse
certains mordus à toutes les folies.
Allons au circuit du Vigeant,
dans la Vienne.
C'est l'un des plus gros
rassemblements de Ferrari de l'année.
Fini le style
Dolce vita aux courbes arrondies.
Depuis les années 80,
les descendants de la 308 font rêver.
Lignes agressives
et angles saillants,
un symbole des années fric.
Moi je l'ai fait.
La star du jour ici,
c'est Joël Rivière.
Rappelez-vous,
c'est le propriétaire de la Enzo.
Il est venu avec
sa prestigieuse voiture.
C'est la 288 GTO...
Mais pas seulement.
Après la F40...
Ce passionné,
ex-président d'une société informatique,
s'est offert les quatre cylindrées
les plus convoitées.
C'est la 288 GTO.
C'est la première voiture
capable de dépasser 300 k/h.
C'est ce qui a donné naissance
à la deuxième supercar de l'histoire,
qui est la F40 qui est là-bas.
Ce sont des objets
très mythiques pour la marque
car, ce sont des voitures très rares.
C'est assez compliqué à avoir,
car, par exemple,
Je ne vends pas les miennes.
Si vous voulez une GTO,
il faut que quelqu'un en vendre une,
et il n'y en a plus à vendre.
Des voitures d'exception
à plusieurs centaines de milliers d'euros.
Mais Joël Rivière
a fait encore plus fort.
Il vient d'acheter cette formule un,
une folie à deux millions et demi d'euros.
Un exemplaire unique
qui a triomphé en Grand Prix
avec Felipe Massa,
le pilote officiel de la Scuderia Ferrari.
Donc là,
j'ai la chance de pouvoir rouler
et posséder cette voiture
formule un depuis quelque temps
et on a l'archétype
de ce qui se fait de mieux.
Au niveau technologie,
voilà ce que ça donne,
avec les palettes pour les vitesses
et l'embrayage à la main.
Vous comprendrez mieux
pourquoi j'ai acheté cette voiture
lorsque vous l'entendrez démarrer.
Parce qu'à démarrer
et à faire rouler,
à mon sens, il n'y a pas mieux
sur terre en termes de bruit.
Pour entendre ce bruit,
Il ne suffit pas
d'acheter la voiture.
Ça ne supporte pas
l'à peu près.
Pour démarrer et préparer
un tel concentré de technologies,
il faut une équipe de dix personnes.
Des mécaniciens venus spécialement
d'Italie aux frais de Joël Rivière.
Prix du week end : 40 000 €.
C'est le prix à payer
pour s'offrir des sensations fortes
le temps de quelques tours de circuit.
Aujourd'hui,
Joël Rivier peut se croire
participer
à la légende Ferrari
sur les traces de Fangio, Crost,
ou Schumacher.
Seize titres de champion
du monde des constructeurs,
209 victoires en Grand Prix,
quinze titres de meilleur pilote
dont sept pour Michael Schumacher.
Un tel héritage,
ça met forcément la pression.
Je vais vous dire que là,
on a un sentiment de bonheur
de la ramener entière.
Ça,
c'est le premier sentiment.
Et après ces quelques tours de piste,
petit débriefing comme
dans un vrai Grand-Prix.
C'est comme les champions, ça ?
- oui.
Oui, c'est look like,
c'est Canada Dry,
ça a le goût, la saveur,
mais c'en est pas, c'est tout comme.
La Formule un fait rêver,
comme elle a
toujours fait rêver Enzo Ferrari.
Cette passion
pour la course se retrouve
jusque dans son restaurant préféré,
juste en face de l'usine.
l'Auberge du Cavalino
Aujourd'hui, c'est toujours un restaurant,
mais aussi un musée
à la gloire de l'ancien pilote,
devenu symbole national en Italie.
Ce restaurant,
c'était un peu son deuxième bureau.
jusqu'à sa mort,
El commendatores a eu sa table
réservée sept jours sur sept,
pas dans la grande salle du restaurant,
mais dans une arrière salle,
interdite au public.
Impossible d'aller voir,
c'est privé.
Pas besoin de négocier bien longtemps,
pour qu'on nous montre
ce qui fait la fierté de l'établissement.
Venez avec moi.
Cest par-là qu'il passait.
Voici la salle d'Enzo Ferrari.
C'est privé,
interdiction de venir ici.
Lui, il s'essayait toujours là-bas.
Quand il venait,
il voulait voir ce tableau allumé.
Une photo
de vielles voitures de course,
comme au temps d'Enzo Ferrari.
Il y avait toujours ce tableau,
et puis ce tableau-là aussi.
Ça, c'est Enzo Ferrari,
pilote.
Son plat préféré c'était
les Niokies à la tomate, les tagliatelles,
les choses simples
Ces journées, il les passait ici,
il regardait le Grands Prix à la télé.
Il faisait tout d'ici,
tout.
C'est dans cette pièce
qu'ont été signés les plus gros contrats.
C'est ici aussi que Enzo Ferrari,
qui fuyait l'agitation des circuits,
a suivi à la télé
la plupart des courses,
avec ces victoires
et ces drames.
Comme ce terrible accident de Niki Lauda
au Grand Prix d'Allemagne en 1976.
Ou encore, six ans plus tard,
la mort de Gilles Villeneuve
en direct
au Grand Prix de Belgique.
Enzo Ferrari
a perdu plusieurs pilotes.
Il a aussi perdu
un de ses deux fils.
Dino, d'une leucémie.
Brillant ingénieur,
Dino était l'héritier tout désigné.
Enzo ne s'en remettra pas.
Après la disparition de ce fils,
il ne quittera
plus jamais ses lunettes noires
et s'en fermera
peu à peu dans le silence.
Avant de mourir
en 1988 à 90 ans.
Depuis, la saga continue
avec un nouveau président,
Luca di Montezemolo.
Et le mythe n'est pas fini,
d'autant que l'entreprise
fait tout pour l'entretenir.
Elle a créé cet atelier un peu
particulier dans l'usine de Maranello.
Voilà, là,
on se déplace en atelier.
Ici, Roberto Valieti
rénove de vieilles carcasses
confiées par
des collectionneurs fortunés.
Elles viennent
du monde entier.
Cette voiture vient des États-Unis,
La 500 TR que vous voyez
à quatre cylindres,
elle, arrive de l'Autriche.
La 250, Tour de France
vient des États-Unis.
Combien coûte
une restauration complète ?
Ça dépend,
mais disons que ça se stabilise
autour de 250 000 €,
tout compris.
Pour rénover ces voitures,
Roberto Valieti dispose d'un petit trésor.
Nous sommes dans nos archives...
Soigneusement conservées,
des milliers de microfilms.
Et là,
vous voyez la fiche de montage.
C'est un dessin
qui a été conçu en 1953.
Là, c'est un carnet écrit à la main
par les mécaniciens de l'époque,
qui faisaient les révisions
après les compétitions.
Depuis la première 125 S en 1947,
Les plans de chaque voiture,
de chaque pièce,
tout a été consigné
et archivé sur ordre d'Enzo Ferrari.
Boîte de vitesses, freins, etc.
Je ne veux pas exagérer,
mais c'est la Bible pour nous.
C'est-à-dire que
ce sont des documents précieux
qui donnent l'ensemble des pièces
qui composent un véhicule entier.
Et là,
ce sont tous les modèles
que Ferrari a construits
depuis le début.
Grâce à ces archives,
Roberto Valieti accomplit des miracles.
Comme avec cette 250
coupés uniques au monde.
C'est une voiture
qui a été construite en 1956,
qui a été exposée
au Salon de Bruxelles
et vendue à cette époque là,
justement.
Apprecier les révisions.
C'est comme
si la voiture sortait d'usine en 1956.
Exactement ça.
Aujourd'hui, ce petit bijou est estimé
à 1 200 000 €,
six fois plus
que la dernière Ferrari neuve.
Un tel engouement
pour ses voitures 50 ans après,
c'est peut être la seule chose
qu'Enzo Ferrari n'avait pas prévue.